hello everyone and welcome to my first
official video uh in in 2023 I'm
covering again from 1973 that's why I
almost messed it up uh but I decided to
show a very nice game played by 10 year
old uh Gary Kasparov maybe he's even
nine here the game was played some
sometimes in 1973 because Sparrow was
born in 1963 on April 14th and as I do
not have the exact date of the game
maybe he was even nine but okay let's
say he was 10 his opponent is shot at
Murat koliev and we do not know much
about his opponent except that he at
some point became a feed a Master with
some rating of 2300 and that uh well uh
judging by this game he was a very
strong player but as that's all we know
I'm wearing a hoodie hope you guys are
and let's start the year off properly
hope this game inspires you uh the 10
year old Kasparov always inspires us as
he was already a monster at that age uh
so yeah let's uh let's check it out
because Sparrow has the white pieces and
he opens with E4 we have E5 9 like to
have three Knights the C6 and the bishop
to B5 going for the Royal Lopez with A6
morat cooliev goes for morphy's defense
Bishop to A4 and Knight to F6 now we
have D4 and now just e captures on D4
this is the absolute Main Line you could
also consider Knight captures an E4 but
that's um even in those days that was
fairly nicely analyzed let's say castles
B5 Bishop to B3 and D5 and the sorry D5
and the white will just capture the pawn
on E5 and okay the game continues but e
captures on D4 is considered to be the
more serious attempt at refuting this
idea by white so he captures on D4 and
now castles is uh pretty much the only
move they play today but because power
plays E5 very very tricky stuff Knight
the E4 and now casparov castles with
Bishop to E7 Rook to E1 again waiting
with the recapture of the D4 Pawn
Knights the C5 attacking the bishop on
A4 and now just Bishop captures on c6d
captors and Knight captures and D4 he he
wins back his spawn
um castles Knight the C3 and now Knight
the E6 offering a trade of knights if
Kasparov obliges then the bishop comes
to E6 then black and also trade queens
and the black is very happy and there is
only one serious attempt at
um uh playing for Advantage here with
white and Kasparov plays exactly that he
plays Knight to the F5 which is very
nice he goes for the G7 Square the queen
can come to G4 and the other uh fun part
about Knight to F5 is that it prevents a
queen trade if you trade Queens then
there's the uh in between move Knight
captures an E7 check and after you
recapture you're just up a full piece
you've grabbed that Bishop so what could
you play here you could consider a move
like let's say Bishop to G5 or you could
even consider uh some other moves maybe
you're gonna play Knights to G5 it's uh
it's still possible but then look at
this Knight captures on E7 this comes
with check Queen captors and F4 and
already white uh gains many many Tempe
here 90s 6 F5 and then Queen G4 and the
bishop can come to G5 the Knight can
come to E4 this is a disaster for black
so black plays Bishop to G5 this is the
absolute best way to play this and now
uh we have Queen to G4 now if the bishop
moves then you might have some problems
okay the Knight here still guards the G7
square but you get the idea of why
Kasparov put the queen on G4 and it's
not easy to meet this um Queen to G4
move you could consider a move like H5
to get the queen away from the G7 Pawn
you could consider a move like F6 you
could consider a move like G6 it seems
like it gets the job done the problem is
look at this Knight to E4 white happily
would sacrifice a piece here and if G
captures on F5 Queen captures you still
don't have a good move now the bishop on
G5 is hanging and it doesn't matter what
you do if you bring the bishop back look
at this Knight F6 check Bishop captures
e captures and now you have all sorts of
nasty ideas like just checkmating in the
black king okay the Knight still guards
G7 but you will just eliminate the
knight at some point you also have to be
careful you don't want to get a back
rank made it so you will have to develop
the bishop first but pretty much
incredibly difficult to defend for black
there is a way like you could play Queen
to D4 and then after Bishop to E3 Queen
to H4 and black still fights but it's
not gonna be easy so in the game Knight
the D4 was played and it is now as of
move 13 that this position has never
been reached again and as you might
imagine for very good reasons uh it's
not uh it's not a very good move now uh
he he had ideas here like if if Kasparov
trades queens and of course why would
Kasparov do that like if Queen captures
on D4 Bishop captures an F5 and now
everything is nicely defended the bishop
is defended by the Queen the queen is
defended by the bishop even if you try
Queen the ages Bishop captures and d8
and everything is perfectly fine so
instead after Knight the D4 caspara
played Bishop captures on G5 he attacked
uh shot at Queen and now Bishop captures
an F5 short attacks Gary's queen queen
to G3 now you will really have to be
careful of what you're doing now there
is no Knight on a E6 guarding the G7
square and here Queen to C8 getting the
queen out of The Bishop's way also
getting the queen out of the D file
because here Mora um was uh afraid of
Rook to D1 but in fact Queen to D7 was
the best move here the the point is that
now I have to rotate the D1 you can play
C5 and there is no good way to move the
Knight play C3 and try and take
advantage of this now let's say Knights
the B1 you even lose this game night the
night's day to check Forks the king and
the queen you can't capture the queen
because uh sorry you can't capture the
Knight because Queen captures on D1 is
Checkmate and if you move the king to F1
or H1 the Knight Will gobble up the
queen delivering check and you will uh
win your opponent's Queen but after
Queen to C8 this is now a problem now
black will have problems bringing the
Rooks into the game and it didn't really
achieve all that much now Rook 8 to D1
comes with tempo as the Knight is
hanging and you can no longer play D5 uh
C5 now the queen no longer guards the D5
Square U along Knight the D5 and all
sorts of uh problems appear out of
nowhere so here your knight captures on
C2 and this is all uh pretty much top
top engine moves from black this is
those are not silly moves uh Rook to E2
and now Queen to E6 uh it seems that
black just gobbled up a pawn and he's
very happy with his position but now
Bishop F6 Kasparov threatens Checkmate
and you cannot play G6 if you play G6
Queen G5 followed by Queen H6 Queen G7
is an Unstoppable Checkmate so here
Bishop to G6 was played and it seems
like black defended everything he
doesn't really have a worry in the world
but that's not really the case because
Parham had something in mind what is it
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it the only move that allows
Kasparov to win the game while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
wonderful idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures on G7 that's what uh uh Gallery
played and now after King captures on G7
look at this Rook captures on C2 now the
bishop cannot move and now uh the
material is equal okay it's Knight
against Bishop but you have opened up
the black King's defenses and it will
now be possible to attack the black king
Rook 8 to d8 offering a trade of Rooks
but Kasparov just doubles up on the D
file Queen to E7 guarding on d8 and now
H4 kaspar is now threatening H5 to win
the bishop so King to h8 and now look at
this spectacular move by casparov Queen
to G5 and now you can't really uh do
nothing uh otherwise you're just gonna
lose the queen you can't move the queen
otherwise uh Rook capture 78 and
everything is now going for that d8
square what you could do is trade on G5
but it's not all that impressive it is
what happened in the game and it seems
like you should be able to play it you
even double up White's G Pawn but look
at what Kasparov had in mind captures
captures and now Rook captures on D2
Rook captures and now okay it seems like
a sparrow is threatening Rook to D7 so
his opponent just stops that and it
seems like black solves all of his
problems uh he has a bishop against the
Knight on an open board there's play on
both sides of the board so Bishop should
be a little bit better than the Knight
and it seems that it will be Kasparov
who will be struggling this game but
every position is unique and this is one
such unique position let's see how
Kasparov plays it pawn to F4 his idea is
he wants to play King F2 King F3 and
push G for F5 and completely box in the
black king uh problem is there is no
good way to activate the black Rook you
don't have access to d8 the The Rook is
covering that and this isn't really
achieving all that much so King to G7 we
have King to F2 now preparing sorry
about that King F2 preparing King F3 and
G4 and now H5 it's the only good way to
seek control play and again it is the
top move recommended by the engine so
Kasparov uh now really should capture
Alpha because now F3 and G4 will be met
with just H captors and G4 nothing
spectacular here so okay G captures on
H6 uh with check King characters and now
King F3 preparing G4 but now he stops IT
Rook to G8 and at least the black Rook
gets some activity uh for for you know
on f8 it really wasn't doing all that
much but now look at this Knight the E4
uh because Sparrow just shows that black
is without a single move the problem is
even if you trade here let's say
captures captures and okay it's a rook
end game with equal material uh still a
white is just completely winning there's
nothing you can do even Rook G3 which
seems like it gains some activity Rook
D7 and now if King to G6 guarding the
pawn here just F5 with check and the
what do you play here King to G5 Rook
captures an F7 and white gets two
connected past pawns completely winning
and if you try this then E6 and again
you will lose the F7 Pawn so there's no
way to activate your pieces in any
possible way so here Bishop to G4 was
played we have King to E3 and now King
to G6 and here uh kaspar was basically
completely winning once he even entered
the end game that's how powerful
Kasparov position was but here his
opponent kind of steals his glory uh he
plays King to G6 and Kasparov ends the
game with Knight to F6 just forking the
rook and the bishop and if you want uh
you know achieve anything you will have
to play something like well there's
really nothing to play I mean it's uh
you you will suffer severe material loss
but even if he his opponent continue
continue defending in the absolute best
possible way let's say Bishop to E6 look
at how something easily casparov can win
the game Knight to F6 now takes away
even more squares from the black Rook uh
you have to move the Rook somewhere
let's say Rook G3 not a problem King F2
and look at this The Rook has no squares
on the on the third rank The Rook has to
go back and it doesn't matter where you
go to this is covered by the Knight this
is covered by the pawn you can go to G6
but now look at this Rook to d8 and all
of the squares here are covered and
there is no good defense against Rook to
h8 or basically uh G4 and then Rook to
h8 that's pretty much it whatever black
plays here let's say you grab a pawn
because there's nothing uh G4 and now
black can either give up The Rook for
Knight and try to suffer for the rest of
the game or you would see something like
let's say Bishop P6 Rook to h8 check
King to G7 Rook the G8 check King to H6
and pawn to G5 leaving black with only
one option Rook captures and then F
captures and G5 and this would result in
Checkmate so absolutely spectacular game
by the 10 or maybe even nine-year-old
Gary Kasparov he completely outplace his
opponent and after a couple of uh not
bad moves couple of weaker moves uh he
he finds this bishop to sorry not this
bishop captures on G7 move which opens
up the black king just a little bit and
then he doesn't even win the game by uh
some sort of uh checkmating attack but
rather he finds this spectacular Queen
to G5 move which forces just a a
brilliant brilliant uh end game for him
so at 10 years old it really you know it
really makes you wonder about your own
uh chess ability at least it does for me
but this is I mean absolutely
spectacular
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed that and that uh you uh started
the year well I thought this would be a
nice game at the kickoff the the year
2023 so hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Michael hope Consulting
Adam Hall to James Mayberry in the
Deepak again for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and everything that happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day